it is April 7 2023 and you're watching
the code report one month ago Vector
database weeviate landed 16 million
dollars in series a funding last week
Pinecone DB just got a check for 28
million at a 700 million valuation and
yesterday chroma an open source project
with only 1.2 GitHub Stars raised 18
million for its embeddings database and
I just launched my own Vector database
this morning we're currently pre-revenue
pre-vision and pre-code and valued at
420 million dollars leave your credit
card details in the comments if you'd
like to invest but you might be
wondering what the hell is a vector
database or what the hell is a vector
even well that's easy a vector is just
an array of numbers but what's cool
about vectors is that they can represent
more complex objects like Words
sentences images or audio files in a
continuous High dimensional space called
an embedding it's kind of like this when
you go to a party all of the jocks sit
around the TV and watch football
meanwhile all the girls find the Dance
Floor while you group together with all
the programming introverts to talk about
vectors in the corner notice how all the
similar objects are grouped together
embeddings work the same way except they
map the semantic meaning of words
together or similar features in
virtually any other data type these
embeddings can then be used for things
like recommendation systems search
engines and even text generation like
chat GPT but once you have your
embeddings the question becomes where do
you store them and how do you query them
quickly that's where Vector databases
come in in a relational database you
have rows and columns in a document
database you have documents and
collections but in a vector database you
have arrays of numbers clustered
together based on similarity which can
be queried with ultra low latency making
it an ideal choice for AI driven
applications relational databases like
postgres have tools like PG Vector to
support this type of functionality and
redis also has first class Vector
support but a bunch of new native Vector
databases are popping up like weeviate
and milvis are open source options
written in go then you have Pinecone
which is extremely popular but is not
open source then you have Chromo which
is based on clickhouse under the hood
and many other options from there let's
jump into some code to see what it looks
like here I'm using chroma and
JavaScript and the first thing I I'll do
is create the client then Define an
embedding function in this case it will
use the openai API to update the
embeddings whenever a new data point is
added each data point is just a document
with an IDE and some text and finally we
can query the database by passing a
string of text just like an llm what's
most interesting though is that in the
query result we get the data back in
addition to an array of distances with a
smaller number indicating a higher
degree of similarity that's pretty cool
but the real reason that these databases
are so hot right now is that they can
extend llms with long-term memory you
start with a general purpose model like
open ai's gpt4 metaslama or Google's
Lambda then provide your own data in a
vector database when the user makes a
prompt you can then query relevant
documents from your own database to
update the context which will customize
the final response and it can also
retrieve historical data to give the AI
long-term memory in addition they also
integrate with tools like link chain
that combine multiple llms together it's
all pretty crazy and I'm working on a
tutorial on my second Channel with Wii
V8 so make sure to subscribe over there
if you really want to dive into this
stuff and lastly in related news if you
check out the top training repos in
GitHub today they're almost all trying
to create artificial general
intelligence like Microsoft's Jarvis
Auto GPT and baby AGI which are tools
that use Vector databases and llms to
prove themselves and this is terrifying
as someone who just became a proofed
engineer I never thought I'd become
obsolete twice in one month this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one